[Music]
oh
no one does Halloween quite like the
Kardashians and on Tuesday Kim proved it
yet again dressing her kids up like
music icons it's really fun to see the
reality star posted this clip to tick
tock featuring her four kiddos North
Saint Chicago and Psalm posing it up for
a Halloween photo shoot
the clip is set to Aaliyah's track miss
you which is fitting since North
channels the late singer Circa 1997 when
she famously posed for a Tommy Hilfiger
campaign I don't know how you're gonna
top that oh but Kim she was just getting
started I swear I'm really good
Northeast little sis Chicago transformed
into Sade rocking all denim a gold wrist
cuff and large gold hoop earrings she
even sported Sade's signature braid
operator
as for Saint he harnessed his inner
Snoop Dog flashing a rock on hand signal
while sporting a checkered shirt and
khaki cargos
and Psalm he dressed as the late rapper
Eazy-E wearing the musician's iconic
Compton cap green pants black shoes and
a black jacket
[Music]
of course it should come as no surprise
Kim's kids would slay these looks I mean
Kim went all out for the spooky holiday
in 2017 when she dressed as Cher Selena
and Aaliyah
[Music]
and while we'll just have to wait and
see what costume Kim wears this year
she's already getting in the spirit
hitting up Knights of the jack in LA
that's the skims founder flashing a
peace sign with Saint during their
festive outing where they were joined by
Kim's sister Courtney Court's youngest
kids Penelope and rain and her hubby
Travis Barker
[Music]
court and Travis have been in full-blown
spooky mode earlier this month they
celebrated the premiere of Halloween
ends with their own Michael myers-themed
party complete with a pumpkin lined path
and 15-foot red skeletons that greeted
guests
[Music]
meanwhile Chloe had a more kid-friendly
bash for the Kardashian kiddos complete
with Halloween gingerbread houses lots
of sweet treats and a Halloween themed
balloon arch we all want to be cute over
here okay
[Music]